I get what I want and if you are no I'm
just gonna climb over you find my yes
the best advice that I would have to
pass to the next generation of women and
as I'm still learning it myself as to
trust your gut and your light and don't
dim your light for anybody and no matter
how many knows you get you look in the
mirror and you tell yourself yes I can
and you continue to push forward no
matter what that's not so today pay no
attention to no I paid no attention to
know it all in fact if you let me tell
it I've never heard no I've never heard
no do not let anyone break your spirit
to try to remove the self-doubt as early
as you can to to support other women to
surround yourself with mentors to seek
out the smartest people in the room to
be your mentors to listen to learn to
stay hungry and to take every
opportunity you can to believe that you
can do it too and not do it ever in an
angry way don't be a woman trying to be
a man in a man's world like be a sister
lift your other like fellow girls up be
all about girl power and just believe in
yourself resist resist and your voice
does matter as someone once told me when
I got my job on The Today Show he said
today you could be drinking the wine
tomorrow you could be picking the grapes
I think success comes and goes and you
have high points and low points in your
career and I think it's really important
how you treat people because the same
people who help you up are going to
catch you when you fall kindness and
compassion should go hand in hand with
ambition and drive to trust yourself to
get grounded in your beliefs and to not
doubt yourself believe in yourself to go
forward and to try to bring your belief
system to the world like I wish someone
has
to me don't settle for a glass or if
they said that to me I wish I would have
believed it because it's true